wir gehen direkt rüber in den deutschen
bundestag kanzler olaf scholz spricht
dort gibt dort einen bericht ab und
danach folgt die befragung dort im
deutschen bundestag indirekt die sich
als g7 verstehen sondern auch die in
asien und in afrika und im süden
amerikas sind einhellig der meinung dass
diese art von politik nicht verfolgt
werden kann auch wenn die einzelnen
perspektiven unterschiedlich sind es
waren gute gespräche auf augenhöhe für
eine welt die multipolar aber auch
multilateral ist
im elmer haben wir uns auch mit den
konsequenzen dieses krieges beschäftigt
und haben gemeinsam eine internet
nationale hunger an der international
food initiative ergriffen mit der wir
beitragen wollen dazu das jetzt nicht
als folge des krieges millionen menschen
auf der welt hunger leiden müssen und
wir haben auch ansonsten solidarität
organisiert wenn es etwa um das thema
der ja noch immer nicht beendet in kurve
9 10 pandemie in der welt geht wir haben
gesprochen über die residenz von
demokratien und natürlich auch wie wir
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten können ein großes wichtiges
thema das nur untergehakt zwischen den
staaten der welt gut funktionieren kann
und deshalb ist es ein großer
fortschritt dass der vorschlag einen
klima club der gleichgerichteten staaten
derjenigen die bis zur mitte dieses
jahrzehnts klimaneutrale industrieländer
wollen zu schaffen dass dieser vorschlag
unterstützung gefunden hat das ist das
eine weitere gute ergebnis aus diesem
g7-treffen in deutschland
und bei der nato bei der nato haben wir
für finnland und schweden die einladung
ausgesprochen dass die mitglieder
unseres verteidigungsbündnisses werden
können ein großer wichtiger schritt für
das verteidigungsbündnis für die
sicherheit im transatlantischen raum und
ganz besonders in europa aber auch ein
wichtiger schritt weil er verbunden ist
auch mit weiteren entscheidungen zur
stärkung unserer ostflanke innerhalb des
nato bündnisses aber auch zur stärkung
der militärischen bereitschaft die dann
300.000 soldaten soldaten umfassen soll
ein wichtiger weg nach vorne für ein
bündnis das sich mehr rüstet für eine
gefahr die von der russischen aggression
aus der ukraine ausgeht und mehr rüstet
dafür dass das eigene territorium und
alle mitglieder der nato auch verteidigt
werden können wenn sie angegriffen
werden ein guter fortschritt
die themen die auf diesen drei gipfeln
verhandelt worden sind spielen natürlich
gleichzeitig eine rolle in brüssel und
auch hier und deshalb bin ich sehr froh
dass wir mit dem fifty five paket im
europäischen räten weiter gekommen sind
dass wir aber gleichzeitig in dieser
woche im deutschen bundestag auch die
pakete verhandeln mit denen die
bundesregierung beschleunigung zustande
bringen will beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien deutschland will
tatsächlich sowie international
vereinbart bis zur mitte dieses
jahrhunderts klimaneutral werden bis
2045 wollen wir das als land schaffen
und deshalb brauchen wir tempo beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien auch
das bringt er jetzt voran
aber es geht nicht nur darum dass wir
diese internationalen verabredungen
treffen dass wir bei dem wichtigen
vorhaben klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden so schnell vorankommen dass wir
uns vorbereiten auf die gefahren die
herrühren aus der möglichkeit dass die
energieversorgung nicht gesichert ist
wenn russland den transit zb von gas
beeinträchtigt und wir sehen ja die
angeblich technischen gründe uns
gegenwärtig schon
beeinträchtigen sondern es geht auch
darum dass wir die folgen für die
bürgerin und bürger dieses landes klar
im blick haben und deshalb ist es ein
guter schritt dass wir an eine wichtige
tradition in deutschland anknüpfen die
sozialpartnerschaft den zusammenarbeit
zwischen staat gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber und unternehmensverbänden
zusammen mit bundesbank und
sachverständigenrat darüber diskutieren
was ist zu tun damit wir die bürgerinnen
und bürger vor diesen dramatischen
preissteigerungen ihrem persönlichen
leben schützen können die konzertierte
aktion hat diese woche am montag das
erste mal getagt sie wird fortgesetzt
werden es ist eine gute kooperation und
aus ihr heraus werden wir die nächsten
schritte entwickeln 30 milliarden haben
wir jetzt entlastungspaket für die
bürgerinnen und bürger auf den weg
gebracht mit der anhebung des
grundfreibetrags mit dem
arbeitnehmerpauschale die wir angehoben
haben mit den möglichkeiten für die
pendlerpauschale die wir verbessert
haben mit einem heizkostenzuschuss für
diejenigen die wohngeld bekommen mit 200
euro für die empfänger von
grundsicherung mit der möglichkeit dass
wir eine wöchentlich 20 euro zahlen für
die kinder die in irgend einem haushalt
leben dass alle kinder für alle kinder
100 euro gezahlt werden dass wir ein
energie geld zahlen und dass wir die eg
pauschale abgeschafft haben aber das
wird nicht reichen und was wir jetzt
brauchen ist dass wir uns unterhaken und
das ist der weg den die konzertierte
aktion beschreitet ein guter weg für
unser land
[Musik]
bevor wir mit der befragung beginnen
mache ich noch mal auf die besonderheit
bei der kanzler befragung nach unserer
parlamentarischen übung aufmerksam der
oder die fragestellerin hat die
möglichkeit gleich noch eine nachfrage
zu stillen zum themenkomplex nachfragen
anderer abgeordneter
so dass er so der kurze bericht von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und hier bei
uns ist unser chef reporter peter tiede
heute stehen ja peter einige punkte
dringend punkte auf dem programm die
jetzt gleich auch in der anschließenden
befragung sicherlich eine rolle spielen
weil der teuer schock die inflation der
krieg in der ukraine wie geht's weiter
in der korona krise jetzt zunächst aber
ein kurzer bericht dass kanzler ist wie
schätzt du denn ein ja da kommt die
lobhudelei also was soll da kannst du
machen sagen ich bin total mist oder
meine politik funktioniert gar nicht und
ich habe auch keine habe auch keinen
plan da ändert sich natürlich selber und
seine ampel und da muss man sagen dass
diese befragung der bundesregierung es
können unterschiedliche minister immer
befragt denn jetzt ist der kanzler daran
findet jeder sitzungswoche stadt und
jetzt dass der kanzler heitmann wie dran
und da ist auch wenn ich dann immer in
der kanzler- dran ist stehen die pille
palle sachen auf der kabinettsliste oder
sachen mit dem man sich schmücken kann
also da stellt man immer den schönen
tannenbaum raus und dann gibt er wird
heute also ein gesetz zur änderung wie
man projekte großprojekte schneller in
deutschland durch kriegt kernprojekt der
ampel heute auf der tagesordnung im
bundeskabinett heute morgen dazu wird
der kanzler sprechen zunächst an befragt
werden oder gesetzentwurf zur einführung
eine chancen aufenthaltsrechts ist so
ein total verbrennt der name der ist so
schön gefärbt ist im prinzip eine
amnestie für ganz viele leute die sich
seit fünf jahren illegal aber straffrei
hier in deutschland aufhält oder eine
duldung haben aber keinen
aufenthaltstitel haben die können quasi
amnestiert werden wie es die usa immer
mal regelmäßig macht mit einwanderern
aus lateinamerika und das sind sachen
mit denen kann man sich schmücken und
dazu wird der kanzler dann gleich
befragt werden er wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich nochmal kurz etwas sagen
zu der kabinettssitzung heute und dann
kommen fragen zunächst zu den themen das
ganze keine stunde oder 75 minuten
dauern zunächst zu den themen die heute
auf der kabinettsliste stand also zum
weihnachtsbaum und den geschenken die
darunter liegen danach können andere
fragen gestellt werden und dann das
heißt also später wird's richtig
spannend jetzt gucken wir mal womit der
weihnachtsbaum geschmückt wird und was
darunter liegt höher noch mal kurz rein
in den bundestag hervor
genommen werden aber der rahmen ist
damit beschrieben ein punkt allerdings
habe ich schon wiederholt und an vielen
stellen gesagt wird sicherlich eine
große rolle spielen die hochwirksamen
sanktionen die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben gegen russland die werden immer
etwas sein was wir einsetzen können wenn
es verletzung von vereinbarungen gibt um
die wir jetzt ja immer noch erst ring
denn tatsächlich findet der brutale
krieg ja unverändert statt
sie können eine nachfrage stärke schön
vielen dank für diese ersten erläuterung
die mir eine erste vorstellung davon
geben was beabsichtigt ist mir stellt
sich die frage warum sie der fragenden
journalisten der deutschen welle nicht
eine ähnliche antwort gegeben haben bei
der pressekonferenz und dass du brüsk
abgewiesen haben verehrter herr
abgeordnete diese frage hat sich bereits
so beantwortet wie ich sie ihnen
beantwortet hatte
danke
nächste fragesteller ist aus der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen jürgen
trittin
man hat darüber müssen wir hier im
studio sprechen bei uns bild
chefreporter peter tiede peter du guckst
entsetzt ist auch er schoss hat wieder
keine antwort auf diese frage geben wir
erinnern uns es gab immer eine
pressekonferenz auf der pressekonferenz
hat eine polnische deutschsprachige
journalistin der deutschen welle den
kanzler nach sicherheitsgarantien der
ukraine befragt und gefragt können sie
sagen welche das sind der kanzler
dagestanden und hat gesagt ja könnte ich
das war seine antwort also eine nicht
antwort ein totaler arroganz anfall dir
auch das persönliche erleben einen kern
dieses kanzlers da legt der ist der ist
so der ist manchmal schnodderig oben
sind unverschämt gegenüber journalisten
und jetzt ist er wieder nachgefragt
worden und hat wieder gefragt hat wieder
einfach gesagt hat aber die frage schon
beantwortet das macht man nicht ist
nicht könig am hofe ist bei den leuten
die in der rechenschaft schuldig ist
nämlich im deutschen bundestag schauen
wir weiter einen jürgen trittin stellt
gerade eine frage allein in diesem klima
gruppe zu bekommen und zu behalten
zunächst mal ist es so dass die
entscheidung des amerikanischen gerichts
ja die amerikanische regierung und
kongress nicht daran hindern die
notwendigen gesetze auf den weg zu
bringen mit denen sie selber
klimapolitik aktiv vorantreiben können
es ging um eine handlungskompetenz der
amerikanischen behörde und ihre freiheit
sich mit eigenen kompetenzen in dieser
frage zu bewegen das ist sicherlich
schwieriger geworden aber ich weiß
sowohl vom präsidenten als auch von hand
carey der in dieser frage sei ein
sonderbeauftragter ist dass ihnen das
ein ganz wichtiges anliegen des
voranzukommen die idee des klima clubs
ist aber ohnehin dass wir uns nicht auf
einen einzigen fahrt festlegen sondern
dass wir akzeptieren und verstehen dass
es unterschiedliche pfade der länder die
dort zusammen arbeiten gibt und dass
diese unterschiedliche pfade auch
tatsächlich
vernünftig und richtig zueinander passen
wenn sie das gleiche ziel verfolgen um
die mitte des jahrhunderts klimaneutrale
wirtschaft zu organisieren das wollen
alle und dann wird es welche wie in
europa geben die mit co2 bepreisung
arbeiten und andere die andere wege
beschreiten wichtig ist dass das ziel
ernsthaft verfolgt wird sie können eine
nachfrage stellt trittin herr
bundeskanzler ich habe in dem
zusammenhang noch eine nachfrage die
sind ja konfrontiert damit dass der
wegfall russischen gases
aufgrund fehlender produktion export und
transportinfrastruktur
sehr schwierig ist
in diesem winter
vor diesem hintergrund haben die g7 wie
ich finde zu recht beschlossen
dass auch die garantien und die
kreditierung von investitionen in solche
infrastruktur bric staaten der g 7
wieder möglich werden soll das erzeugt
aber einen konflikt mit dem ziel was sie
eben genannt haben 2045 klimaneutral zu
sein 2035 möglichst auch unsere
stromversorgung umgestellt zu haben ich
würde es ja nicht fragen wie wollen sie
eigentlich in diesen kreditierung und
exportkreditversicherungen eine
zeitliche limitierung einführen die das
ziel der dekarbonisierung bei diesen
notwendigen maßnahmen nicht in frage
gestellt wir können das sehr gut
verstehen anderen eigenen
herausforderung die wir haben wir wissen
wir haben jetzt ganz aktuell die
herausforderung dass wir infrastrukturen
etablieren mit den gast nach deutschland
gebracht werden kann auf andere weise
als es bisher der fall ist wenn wir das
nicht tun würden dann würden wir es
nicht sicher spürten wir nicht
gewährleisten können dass wir immer
unabhängig sind von einzelnen importeur
und deshalb machen diese investitionen
sind aber sie halten deutschland ja
nicht davon ab das gleiche ziel weiter
zu verfolgen nämlich
2045 spätestens co2 neutral zu
wirtschaften und die infrastrukturen die
wir zb hier etablieren wollen wir immer
auch mit dem blick auf die perspektive
bauen dass sie später für wasserstoff
importe zb genutzt werden können und das
ist ein gleichermaßen auch die
perspektive für viele andere länder wenn
dort neue infrastrukturen errichtet
werden dann müssen sie sinn machen bei
der verfolgung des 1,5 grad zieles dann
müssen sie auch solche perspektiven mit
in den blick nehmen und das ist auch das
was sich sehr sorgfältig ausgearbeitet
aus der verständigung der g7 ergeben
aber gleichzeitig sind sie auch eine
gute botschaft für länder wie afrika zum
beispiel genau in dieser übergangsphase
in der wir uns befinden
auch noch neue investitionen benötigen
vielen dank nächste frage aus der
fdp-fraktion können wir da mal kurz raus
das darf nicht passieren das ist ein
lapsus wirklich wie aus der kolonialzeit
ich habe noch nicht mal geschrieben dann
kann es da geht manchmal sind um so wie
auf einer cocos insel sagte söder
neulich da die staatsmänner
empfangen in bayern mit lauter trachten
dingsbums und sah aus wie als wenn der
kaiser kommt noch eine kokosnuss insel
und das war jetzt wirklich kokos
kokosnuss insel das war kolonialzeit
ländern wie afrika hallo das ist ein
kontinent diesen riesen konnten
kontinent da sind so viele also für
unterschiedliche kulturen und das darf
eigentlich nicht passieren länder wie
afrika das ist fast wie donald trump
aber die hat nur länder und hauptstädte
verwechselt nicht schlecht als sie
kontinenten mit ländern das sollte
wirklich nicht passieren
da mal einmal über die inhaltliche
aussage gerade von unserem bundeskanzler
sperrung wurde angesprochen auf diesen
klima klopp vielleicht kannst du dann
nochmal einmal das kurz erläutern was
genau dahinter steckt die haben muss
einmal kurz erklären also das was der
kanzler dann macht das immer ganz
geschickt den bogen nehmen das war eine
frage vom ampel abgeordneten jürgen
trittin der jetzt sagen wir in
energiefragen und beziehung längst nicht
ganz so unbeliebt ist und auch nicht mit
moskau aber dass er mal hingestellt hat
natürlich ganz gezielt nach
amerikanischen gas gefragt aber solche
fragen nimmt man natürlich auch nach der
infrastruktur und nach klima die nimmt
man auf als kanzler und dann geschickt
auf die eigene politik zu lenken und
wieder auf die sieben war ja quasi
gastgeber war auf schloss elmau und der
klima club soll eigentlich so eine
initiative seien die von g7 ausgibt
ausgibt dass man auch schwellenländer
und entwicklungsländer mit nem und dass
man bereit willi geländer so eine art
koalition der willigen fürs klima und
dass man da auch ein bisschen geld zur
verfügung stellt und ärmeren ländern
hilft und das ist dieser klima klub von
dem der kanzler spricht dann hat man so
schöne begriffe wie vor fit war 55 jahre
man soll fit sein für 20 55 das sind
floskeln die er da nimmt und wo er sich
selber feiert für projekte die sind
angegangen worden sind auch wichtig sind
auch vernünftig aber nimmt eine frage
natürlich auf die kommt aus der
regierung aus der regierungsfraktion und
die gibt den kanzler dann die
möglichkeit noch mal eine kugel an den
weihnachtsbaum zu hängen peter du wirst
jetzt weiter im stillen kämmerlein
sozusagen für uns alles was im bundestag
passiert verfolgen und uns hier in
dieser sendung natürlich immer auf dem
laufenden halten
die euro-länder und
auch alle weiteren themen man muss ganz
ernste sind dringende themen heute
unterwegs bestimmt auch die ein oder
andere unangenehme frage für den kanzler
geben da ist uns auf dem laufenden sehen
wir uns gleich wieder kleinen dank